ça dirait de faire partie de la caméra
cachée
[Applaudissements]
ça marche oh pardon j'ai rien sur moi je
n'ai rien sur moi
je parlais d'argent ah d'accord
vous allez ma voiture à nouveau vous
l'avez ma voiture à nouveau bah c'est
pas pour la laver vous venez ici je suis
passé moi
le fait
parce que
moi je fais ça Halloween
comme ça
[Musique]
oh là là
pourquoi pas comme ça moi je vous en
fait une prise d'urine non non rien du
tout
[Musique]
là sur le coin vous faites pipi là
dedans d'accord
une petite goutte ça suffit
ça y est
je vais vous refaire le pansement moi je
serai plus tranquille où j'ai pas
fait pour les maux de tête
bon on dit ça puis après on a mal à la
tête et après on est content d'avoir un
truc quand même voilà
ça ira très bien avec le doigt c'est
beaucoup plus joli comme ça non puis en
plus il fait froid voilà
un peu
de la gueule quoi
juste pour le
pas de problème
de grosses couilles quand vous faites un
effort non que les petites couilles
ça va faire mal un peu au début et puis
après je vais faire je vais faire un TR
c'est quoi ça un toucher
rectalins
[Rires]
touche pas ma génisse non la viande
hachée
laisse-moi faire mes revendications
pourquoi tu fais ça Brother pourquoi tu
fais ça
je te prends pas la tête regarde tu as
gâché des heures de travail je m'en fous
de l'autre côté c'est pareil
hop
faut que mon bœuf est malade si tu vas
manger pour moi tu vas vomir en fait
de violence ça sert à rien c'est un
engendrer rien tu sais la violence ça
n'engendra rien
[Musique]
E
alors attention monsieur attention à toi
attention attention tu sais
moi non plus faut pas jouer avec mes
mères et toi c'est pas de la provoc que
tu fais
c'est
ça allait mal pour toi
je t'ai rien dit je t'ai rien fait toi
tu arrives
qu'est-ce que tu fais regarde tu
m'enlèves ma puce
je vous ai raté
tu as gagné je suis pas prêt de bouffer
ce soir moi
ça va
quoi
non
je vais la je fais
à killing non non
OK et qu'est-ce que je vais manger moi
ce soir
il y a quelqu'un là
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans le
frigidaire
c'est qui
qui t'a mis là c'est moi mais je pensais
que c'était la qualité téléphonique et
elle marche pas la porte
merci
la main dans votre boîte aux lettres dis
donc
impossible de retirer les dents
vous avez une trop petite
à boire là parce que je me sens tout
fait je saigne
c'est du sang
[Musique]
comme ça
merci beaucoup madame
je suis un peu d'hypoglycémie en plus
tenez-moi un petit truc à manger
alors pour donner des sandwichs il y a
plus personne
[Musique]
c'est fragile
vous aurez posé vous serez parti là-bas
vous avez pas mis clignotant aussi
vous avez pas mis clignotant
pour rigoler
c'est bien ça
non
[Musique]
c'est gentil j'attends 5 minutes alors
merci Xavier trouvé où ils étaient
tombés
et vous avez votre papier location votre
numéro non voilà alors
et alors et voilà et c'est les skis ah
c'est parce que vous êtes de France 2
alors
reportage ah d'accord voilà tant pis
alors voilà au revoir
mission sans aucun doute pour la caméra
cachée
ça dirait de faire partie de la caméra
dans ton sac tu te retournes et tu me
mets une gifle d'accord
S
ça veut dire quoi et mon chéquier alors
bah dis donc ça va pas tu es pas là
qu'est-ce qui se passe
non mais ça va pas non
ça veut dire quoi c'est joué on dit que
cette fois-ci serait très naturel
si je peux me permettre un petit peu
moins fort d'accord vous essayez juste
de prendre de faire comme ça et puis moi
d'accord j'essaie de pousser le truc et
vous allez continuer et puis après
on y va top donc ça va pas ou quoi vous
touchez pas à mon sac non
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour la caméra cachée
vous m'avez eu je suis désolé j'avais
pas vu mais j'avais mais non je te
reconnais
[__] c'est pas vrai
pour passer à la télé bah je sais pas
combien il faut régler
ce qu'on veut
donner 100 francs d'accord ouais c'est
gentil tu es sympa allez ciao ok non je
déconne pour les sandales et les gens
c'est gentil toi
[Musique]